hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions the
question today is what is negative 1 ^
pi equal to I think our job from India
in Delhi for suggesting this problem can
you figure it out give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for a solution we start out
with the identity that e to the power of
I theta is equal to the cosine of theta
plus I times the sine of theta let's
substitute theta is equal to PI we get e
to the power of I pi is equal to cosine
of pi plus I times the sine of pi since
the cosine of pi is equal to negative 1
and the sine of pi is equal to 0 this
simplifies to be negative 1 and we get
the famous identity that e to the I pi
is equal to negative 1 let me just flip
this equation around we're now going to
raise both sides to the power of Pi we
can then evaluate what negative 1 to the
power of Pi is equal to this is equal to
e to the I pi all raised to the power of
Pi using the rules of exponents we get
that this is equal to e to the I times
pi squared now we again use a formula
for e to the I theta and we substitute
in theta is equal to pi squared so we
get this is equal to cosine of PI
squared plus I times the sine of pi
squared and that's the exact form we can
also get the approximate form which is
negative point 903 minus 0.4 300i
and that's what negative 1 to the power
of pi is equal to happy pi day thanks
for watching these math videos available
for free on youtube build confidence for
students and inspire mathematical
discovery for viewers around the world
they have over a hundred million views
and over 1 million subscriber
please subscribe for free to get the
news videos and evil me a puzzle or math
topic pressure and mind your decisions
calm B so choose you can check out my
merchandise listed on teespring and you
can check my books which are listed in
the video description you can also
support me on patreon thanks for
watching and thanks for your support